so we have a new prime minister but does
that mean the roller coaster in markets
is coming to an end let's have a look at
where we have been it's been quite a
ride hasn't it this is showing you the
pound against the US dollar the highest
line is the stronger the pound is and
just look at where we've come from
that's the moment where Liz trust was
appointed that's the mini budget uh that
we had just look at what happened to
Sterling after that that enormous fall
down to the lowest level in history
since the creation of the dollar since
U.S Independence and then it started to
rise so that roller coaster continue to
be going up then quasi quateng was five
Jeremy Hunt coming in and Liz truss of
course resigning and you can maybe just
about see a blip upwards uh when we
learned that Richard Cena was going to
be prime minister but that's not the
only roller coaster ride we've also had
interest rates of course the interest
rates the government faces but also the
ones that we Face they've been changing
a lot as well this shows you
expectations for where Bank of England
interest rates which obviously feeds
into our mortgages it's ending in the
next few years so we're looking out into
the future here and just look may seem
kind of extraordinary but back in
February it was going to be very low end
need but then those expectations
increased so in August going up up and
then in September early September you
can see that line getting higher and
higher expectation from interest rates
feeding into our mortgage rates but look
at what happens after the mini budget
that red line getting up to
extraordinary uh high levels basically
based on recent history up above six
percent but since then look things have
started to improve certainly if you've
got a mortgage down uh to around kind of
five percent next year and who knows
where that goes in the future still
higher than it was uh before so that
certainly has calmed down the
expectation is it might well continue to
calm down but there's a lot of work left
for Jeremy Hunt and indeed British unac
to do in future filling in the black
hole in the public finances the one
thing they said they want to do now at
the moment many people think it's around
70 billion pounds of spending cuts tax
Rises you might well need and we've had
some of it already haven't we from
Jeremy Hunt where he kind of undid lots
of parts of the mini budget that raised
about 32 billion pounds but there's
still about 38 billion pounds left to
fill so how how will they get that will
that be spending cuts will it be
something else we will have to see but
meanwhile the back story for the UK
economy it's unfortunately not all that
promising right now this is showing you
something called a purchasing manager's
index but the main thing you need to
know is if the line is in the Blue Area
the economy is expanding if it's in a
red area there it means we're
Contracting them right now look at this
line look at where it is right now it's
in contraction territory suggesting that
even as this prime minister begins his
time in Downing Street the UK economy
could already be in recession